2022 année anniversaire à versailles 300
ans du couronnement de louis 15 et
surtout les 400 ans de la naissance de
molière jean baptiste poquelin est né le
15 janvier 16 122 la ville va rendre
hommage au dramaturge exposition dès le
15 janvier à l'espace richaud en
attendant le mois molière qui se tient
tous les ans en juin dans la cité royale
une statue en bronze sera également
installé dans le jardin du futur office
de tourisme elle sera inaugurée au
moment de la biennale d'architecturé du
paysage labat deuxième édition revient
justement à versailles du 13 mai au 13
juillet lancé par la région
ile-de-france l'événement aura pour
thème terre et ville expositions
conférences au programme en 2019 la
biennale avait attiré deux cent mille
visiteurs les yvelinois disposeront d'un
deuxième tramway dans les yvelines après
le thé 6 en 2014 c'est le thé 13 qui
sera mise en circulation en juillet la
ligne reliera en 30 minutes saint
germain en laye à saint-cyr-l'ecole les
rames d'une capacité de 250 places
emprunteront le réseau ferré déjà
existants et de nouvelles voies des
essais sont effectués jusqu'à l'été en
septembre les élans courtois et maurepas
siens pourront en profiter le centre
aquatique intercommunal caste alias sera
inauguré à la rentrée 2022 cinq bassins
dont un lui dit qu'un en extérieure
chauffée à 28 degrés ouvert toute
l'année le complexe est situé en lieu et
place de l'ancienne piscine de maurepas
coût total 24 millions d'euros le
paris-nice 2022 devrait partir des
yvelines en mars pour la treizième année
consécutive un partenariat lie le
département à l'organisateur à etsaut
jusqu'en 2025 le parcours de la course
au soleil sera dévoilé le 5 janvier en
2021 saint cyr l'école et - ville sur
mansion été ville départ de la
compétition cycliste pour la deuxième
fois de sa jeune histoire le vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
les championnats du monde de cyclisme
sur piste c'est du 12 au 16 octobre
prochain en 2015 la france s'était
classée première avec 7 médailles dont 5
en or devant un public bouillant 25000
spectateurs s'étaient pressés dans les
gradins saint quentinois sur les cinq
jours des mondiaux le vélodrome c'était
des jo de paris 2024 tout comme la
colline d'elancourt théâtre des épreuves
de vtt et les travaux de la piste
olympique doivent démarrer à la fin de
l'année et durer jusqu'en 2024 long de 4
km le parcours prendra une grande partie
du tracé existant en 2025 espace sera
ouvert au public après de nouveaux
travaux
enfin côté travaux à retenir également
cette année toujours l encours premier
coup de pioche prévus pour le futur
commissariat d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines situé dans la
zone des quatre arbres ouverture en 2024
le début de la rénovation urbaine du
bois de l'étang à la verrière avec en
première étape la réhabilitation de 400
logements 200 appartements seront eux
démoli en 2024 le lancement de la
construction de la passerelle piétons
cyclistes entre poissy et carrières sous
poissy un ouvrage au dessus de la scène
de 300 mètres de long 5 mètres de large
qui sera accessible en 2024 ou 2025
enfin l'enfouissement de la nationale 10
va se poursuivre toute cette année à
trappes et d'ici 2023 un nouveau
giratoire sera aménagé au carrefour du
pavillon bleu c'est la deuxième phase de
ce chantier d'envergure qui va durer
jusqu'en 2028